basically going to tell them to not make
content unless it's in a micro Community
that's local but if you're trying to
like compete with the best fitness
influencers at making content while
running a local gym you're not going to
be better than them in making content B
the distribution of the content is going
to be National which is not helpful for
your local gym which is the only way you
can monetize if you want to make content
make it in a group that's like local
Dallas moms should you post yes should
it be your primary acquisition strategy
probably not in the short term my whole
view is just if you're a local business
small business show that you're active
what's the highest and best use of my
times it's not that it doesn't work it's
just is it the best thing to do